things this sunday at 3 30 pm eastern as
part of the new york review of books
35th anniversary
you're watching book tv
48 hours of programs about books authors
and the publishing industry
every weekend here on c-span 2.
next william bundy and his book a
tangled web
mr bundy served on the intelligent
staffs of presidents truman and
eisenhower and went on to hold senior
foreign policy positions in the kennedy
and johnson administrations
he's written this book about u.s foreign
policy during the nixon administration
mr bundy spoke earlier this month at the
carnegie council on ethics and
international affairs in new york city
good afternoon i'm joanne myers director
of merrell house programs and i'd like
to welcome our members our guests and
c-spend to the carnegie council series
on the legacy of leadership
this afternoon we are very privileged to
have as our guest speaker william bundy
who has written a book
and richard nixon a tangled web the
making of foreign policy in the nixon
presidency
the administration of richard nixon is
perhaps the most intensely studied of
all post-war presidencies
his term of office began in january 1969
and ended with his resignation in august
1974.
president nixon along with henry
kissinger his one-time national security
adviser and later secretary of state
were responsible for a foreign policy
during one of the most troubling eras in
american history
although we cannot pretend to know all
the factors that might have influenced
the decisions taken by these two
collaborators
our guest this afternoon makes a strong
case for re-examining their foreign
policy initiatives and the nostalgia
that has recently resurfaced around u.s
foreign fares as conducted by nixon and
kissinger
william bundy is known as a foreign
affairs mandarin
he is a descendant of a very
distinguished family with a long and
devoted record of service to our country
having served as advisers to presidents
during some of the most difficult years
of the cold war he embodies the idealism
that animated american policy after
world war ii
now with his recently published book a
tangled web mr bundy has utilized his
experience as a practitioner writing
knowledgeably with superior insights
about a period in which he served and
from which we have much to learn
after graduation from harvard law school
he went to washington as a corporate
lawyer
actually it was at the same time that
nixon was in congress
shortly thereafter he embarked on a
career in government service that
spanned two decades
he rose steadily through the ranks of
being an analyst with a cia in the 1950s
which is the same time nixon was vice
president
to serving in senior positions in the
defense and state departments under
kennedy and johnson
with special responsibilities for u.s
policy towards southeast asia
after leaving government he served as
editor of foreign affairs for 12 years
now won't you please join me in giving a
very warm welcome to one of the best and
brightest that our nation has witnessed
in the last half century william bundy
[Applause]
that's a marvelous summary of my
checkered career joanne
i was grateful
um
my book
standing here
the tangled web is a comprehensive
history of american foreign policy in
the nixon presidency
an introductory chapter covers nixon's
substantial previous exposure
as congress in congress from 47 to 50
through 52 and then as vice president
under eisenhower from 53 to 61
as well as the temple the tumultuous
election year 1968
in which nixon barely beat hubert
humphrey
in the midst of an ongoing effort by
president lyndon johnson
which nixon had done his best to derail
through a lady named anna chennault
i've covered that episode in my first
chapter
i won't pursue it further tonight but it
was a very instructive one and rather an
indication of
nixon's addiction to secrecy
there's also a chapter on what came
after
terry carrying the story to the mid
1970s in poly policy areas where pivotal
steps had been taken under nixon
in short the book covers the essential
events in american foreign policy
right from 1950 to 1977 the core years
of the cold war
it's fairly long but as many reviewers
have noted and which i'm deeply indebted
to my editor elizabeth sifton
crisply written also well signposted so
that readers who do not want to know the
details of arms control or
similar subjects can skip without losing
the thread
in the words of one reviewer tony jutt
in the new york review of books
the years 1968-75
were the hinge
on which the second half of our century
turned
a great many of the top problems
in today's headlines either originated
then
or went through important changes
it was an extraordinarily important
period from every standpoint
most of you will remember some of the
key events let me just run through them
quickly
the extrication of u.s forces from the
war in indochina the vietnam war as
we've always called it
the reopening after 25 years of
hostility and military conflict
of peaceful dealings between the u.s and
china the opening to china as it was
called
made possible
by the fact that china and the soviet
union once collaborators had become
outright enemies but achieved
dramatically under nixon
in the anti-communist western alliance
which where while west germany remained
a loyal member of nato and u.s ally it
undertook under a new chancellor billy
brandt
its own independent policy aust politik
reaching out to the soviet union and the
eastern communist countries in new and
important ways
an initiative nixon intensely disliked
but accepted with no public disagreement
next the u.s
being no longer able to sustain the
totally dominant position it had held in
the economic structure of the
non-communist nations since the second
world war
abandoned the fixed price for gold that
had been the centerpiece of that bretton
woods structure and led the way
to the floating exchange rates that have
prevailed ever since
in the same economic area the west's
insatiable demand for oil whose supply
was controlled or dominated by middle
eastern countries
led to an energy crisis in 1973 in 1974
with memorable gas lines and shortages
in america and heavy continuing costs
for years
that same crisis coincided
with a renewed war between israel and
key arab nations
egypt and syria
the fourth since israel's creation in
1948 and by far the most hard fought
while the u.s did not commit u.s forces
in that war
its military aid to israel played a
vital part
and in the diplomacy that followed
largely in the person of henry kissinger
who was by then secretary of state
he put through a series of withdrawal
agreements and along the way
got the major oil producers to abandon
their embargo on oil shipments
but they could not undo the fourfold oil
price rise imposed in 1973
which lasted painfully for the next
dozen years
in general america's energy policy
nixon's responsibility was slow to
respond and weak which damaged us for a
long time
now with these remarkable events there
emerged in these years
an extraordinary group of powerful and
colorful individuals in charge of the
foreign policies of their countries
in china premier joe and lai
subordinate entitled to chairman mao
zedong but in fact the prime mover in
china's new policy to bury the past and
seek u.s support
against what appeared for a time to be
an acute soviet military threat
in the soviet union
communist party chairman leonid brezhnev
prepared for change by the first tremors
of the economic failures that were to
play a crucial part in the collapse of
the soviet system in the 1980s
hence ready to negotiate seriously for
the first time over levels of strategic
nuclear weapons
in europe
billy bryant eager along with soviet
leaders for new treaties with the soviet
union in poland including a new
agreement over berlin more favorable to
the west and more stable
in israel the strong team of prime
minister golda meir
and her ambassador to the u.s yitshak
rabin
playing a role that was under the
surface but very important
in egypt after the death of the
legendary pan-arab and anti-american
gamal abdul nasser in 1970 the hither
unto the two unknown anwar el-sadat a
moderate arab leader prepared to
negotiate seriously with the u.s and
eventually with israel
two long-time friends to the u.s the
shah of iran mohammed riza
pallavi and
yaya khan the military ruler of pakistan
and one leader in southeast asia in
south asia prime minister indira gandhi
of india who varied from remote coolness
to outright hostility
in the 1971 crisis that led to the
emergence of bangladesh in what had been
east pakistan
and in america itself
two individuals nixon himself and henry
kissinger
who was originally his national security
adviser and after september 1973
secretary of state
while the two stayed in touch with the
state and defense departments the joint
chiefs of staff and the cia
most of their decisions were made
privately
they made a big show then and later
of deciding issues on the basis of
objective judgment of the u.s national
interest i can almost hear henry's voice
moulding those words
but in fact
both men from their past experience
had a set of intense personal or
national likes and dislikes
good guys and bad guys
and set policy accordingly
one example among many was their shared
dislike of japan
as the white house became the center of
a foreign policy there was notably
little consultation with members of
congress
either on action programs or even on the
major lines of policy
that was dramatically illustrated to me
the other day when i read
in the memoirs dean atchison there's a
new biography of him
he noted that as he said as he finished
his term as secretary he went up to the
hill to meet with the senate committee
on foreign relations and it was the 50th
time he had done so
i would venture that in the nixon
administration
senior officials of any kind
meeting with that committee probably not
more than 10 times and nowhere near as
authoritatively
far more than in any other presidency in
modern times this was a two-man show
nixon was acutely conscious of public
opinion and the importance of the news
media
and was often able to appeal
successfully to both through effective
speeches
but he kept his intentions tightly
to nix to himself and kissing her and
often deceive the country
by pursuing one policy and
by announcing one policy and pursuing
another
hence the title of the book which comes
from the well-known lines of sir walter
scott
oh what a tangled web we weave when
first we practice to deceive
part of the same pattern was nixon's
resort to covert operations
a habit acquired in the eisenhower years
when i served in government incidentally
the foremost and most lamentable example
was the plot he had the cia cook up
to undo the results of the 1970 election
of salvador allende in chile
by a military coup
of course we have chile in the news
today
an effort that was aborted but not till
after the plotters had killed
the moderate chief of the chilean army
other presidents had taken similar
measures but they had fallen into disuse
till nixon revived them
among nixon's main policy decisions
for most of which until the middle east
war at the height of watergate
he was indeed the center of policy and
kissing of only its executor
the first entry has to be the
extrication from the vietnam war
as he took office it was clear to all
that the country had given up on the war
and that it was imperative to get
american forces out
not later than the end of nixon's first
four-year term
and if he had done so systematically as
some of his advisers urged and planned
in all likelihood he would have got the
same kind of
lash or surge in his favor that
eisenhower experienced when he got a
ceasefire in korea in 1953
in nixon's first year
he
gave an eloquent speech in october 1969
announcing a policy of withdrawal
of u.s forces training and arming the
south vietnamese and negotiating with
north vietnam tortoise ceasefire
but instead
first by a secret bombing program he
began in his very first month in office
then by a ground force incursion in the
spring of 1970
memorable to many of us for many reasons
nixon brought a heather to neutral
cambodia into the war
in 1972 a ceasefire was finally achieved
in the in the rest of indochina
not primarily by the secret negotiations
of henry kissinger despite the award of
the nobel prize to him in 1973
but in fact
pretty clearly
by the use of u.s air power on a massive
scale
first to beat back and all out north
vietnamese ground defensive and then to
attack north vietnamese to far targets
for targets far harder than it ever done
done before
crucially the american public was
prepared to accept such bombing on this
occasion
partly because of the communist
defensive but in large part because
nixon had shown himself or
taken up the image of a man of peace
through the china opening and then by
revealing dramatically the secret talks
kissinger had been conducting with the
north vietnamese
but in this
1973 period
i was reminiscing about it with john
bradamus before we started this evening
when the communist
khmer rouge already in power
in cambodia refused to comply
nixon's resort to drastic b-52 bombing
there
finally outraged congress to the point
where it voted decisively in june 1973
to end american involvement in all
military operations in southeast asia
in their memoirs nixon and kissinger
blamed the watergate scandal to which i
shall return
for this and other failures
i argue that the real cause
was deception and failure to consult
solidly with congress
by then
nixon yearned for a degree of
presidential power
totally incompatible with the
constitution
i think i'm practically repeating the
words that john bradham has uttered
across the street in the council on
foreign relations that february or march
may
now perhaps the greatest
genuine success for nixon was the
opening to china the jewel and the crown
in the nixon library in california the
centerpiece is a picture of his historic
trip there in 1972
after a visit by kissinger in july 1971
had opened the way
and in the run-up to that opening
and another important plus rarely noted
was a september 1969 statement
by elliot richardson then under
secretary of state
at a time when secret u.s intelligence
sources were picking up strong
indications that the soviets were
mounting a major airstrike against
china's
nuclear weapons con complex which was
well within reach of soviet airbases
the richardson statement said simply
that the u.s would be quote deeply
disturbed if the soviet union in china
got into a real war
while the evidence on this episode has
never been conclusive i join
as not always
with henry kissinger in believing that
this statement may have headed off
a devastating war
i suppose one might argue that for the
two communist giants to fight each other
would have been in the u.s interest
i think on the contrary that any major
nuclear exchange
including one between india and pakistan
today
would be a fateful downward step for
international relations and for the
world as a whole
moreover
in kissing his first talks with joe and
lai
he was able not only to defend america's
close ties with japan as a factor for
peace
but to persuade joe that china japan was
not a threat as china's leaders then
believed a year later japan and china
normalized their relations
and there has never been a repeat of the
maneuvering between the two asian great
powers that marked the period before
world war ii and contributed to that war
these two easings of key relationships
have hardly been noted by historians
perhaps any administ american
administration would have worked in
these directions but i still gave nixon
and kissinger credit for actually doing
so
after these first breakthroughs however
the new china thai did i think great
harm
when china's ally pakistan
in that same year 1971 first oppressed
east pakistan and then got into war with
india over it
it was a war the u.s should have tried
to head off
instead
nixon and kissinger
perhaps prodded by joe and lie more than
present records reveal
sided solidly with pakistan
then when war came the two were
persuaded by a single intelligence
report unsupported by other evidence
that nix that india was about to attack
west pakistan
the heartland of the country
so that they took the extraordinary step
of sending the giant aircraft carrier
enterprise
nuclear-powered and carrying nuclear
weapons
into the indian ocean
as it turned out the war wound down
anyway
but the american action was widely noted
and resented in india as the rawest kind
of nuclear weapons pressure
india already had a research nuclear
program oriented to civilian uses
within two years of the enterprise foray
it had firmed up its program in a
weapons direction with first tests in
1974 and 1975.
as we all know pakistan responded as it
was bound to do
so that a nuclear exchange in southeast
asia is today in the judgment of many
the greatest single threat to world
peace
we may never know
whether the enterprise episode had a
major effect on india's nuclear
decisions
but the connection is all too plausible
on the chronology alone
if it was true nixon has much to answer
for
i should add that in this highly
critical appraisal of u.s policy in the
indo-pakistan crisis
i am far from alone among historians
stephen ambrose the eminent historian
has been equally critical in his
three-volume biography of nixon
why nixon and kissinger acted as they
did
is puzzling
i believe
nixon kissinger in particular was one
might say almost seduced by joe and lies
legendary charm and sophistication
i paused to say that i rate joe at the
very top among statesmen not only for
this period but for all time
in terms of serving his country's
interests
but both americans were also guided by
extreme balance of power thinking
misreading the decisive regional factors
and getting the us deeply involved in
the situation in which there were no
u.s american national interests that
warranted the risks they took
their policy toward this crisis
was also marked
by examples of extreme by extreme
examples of
deception
that as often happens leaked to their
special discredit
turning now to u.s soviet relations
when they came into power nixon
reluctantly
kissing her eagerly
picked up on the strategic arms control
talks already proposed and planned under
president johnson
so that these formed the backbone of
dealings in the first three nixon years
and finally at the memorable first
soviet summit in moscow in may 1972
an effective agreement
capping anti-ballistic missiles abm's as
they were called
and a much looser agreement for ceilings
on offensive strategic
missiles were reached
in later years
military establishments and civilian
hardliners on both sides
froze the arms control process and
limited progress until the late 1980s
but the wider pattern of agreements
reached at the 1972 and 1973
summits
had a major effect i believe
in getting the two nations used to
dealing with each other
laying the groundwork for the dramatic
arms control deals reagan was later able
to make
on the other hand
what briefly appeared to be progress
toward extensive soviet american
economic dealings
founded in
1974
when they were linked
by the powerful senator henry jackson in
particular
to a firm soviet commitment to permit
high levels of immigration
of soviet jews
on this subject i believe frankly that
the best was the enemy of the good
and that nixon and kissinger were right
in arguing that quiet diplomacy would
have done more to get jews out
then a link to trade and investment
i believe too
though the issue really didn't come up
in the nixon presidency
that such economic ties were always in
the long-term u.s interest much more
important for economic welfare
in the soviet union in russia and
responsible policies than they could
ever have been for soviet military
strength
in the last years of his life nixon
himself became a strong supporter of
large-scale american aid to russia
he may well have been right the second
time
after the nixon era the banner of dayton
was picked up for the countries of
western europe
led by the germany of billy brunt and
his successor helmut schmidt
adopting kissinger's thinking rather
than nixon's greater skepticism
president ford brought the u.s fully
into the helsinki accords of 1975
which i believe contrary to some
conservatives contributed substantially
to the eventual end of the cold war in
1989 to 1991
by opening up eastern europe and by
promoting concern for human rights
within the soviet union itself
among the many factors that led to the
soviet collapse
reagan's military build up in the 1980s
and subsequent and his subsequent arms
control deals deserve a place
but i believe that the most basic factor
of all
was the collapse of the soviet economy
of the whole soviet system
that started in the nixon era but was
little understood at that time
one other nixon policy towards iran
must be put high on the list of failures
nixon never forgot
that the shah had been saved in 1953
by an american covert operation
and in his years out of office kept up
contacts with him
then in 1973
with the oil crisis in full swing
it was the shah who took the lead
in jacking up the oil price several
times over
he wanted the money for the welfare of
his people but also to make iran a
dominant military power in the area
nixon fully supported that ambition and
in 1972 gave the shaw the keys to the
store
full access to buy u.s weapons with his
oil money
the result was a fantastic build up
including an influx of 25 000
american technicians into parts of iran
that had hardly seen westerners
it was not a good mix
and many objective experts believe and
iranians particularly i've talked to
about this
that it aroused feelings
that made the eventual iranian
revolution
against the shah in 1978 and 1979
much more extreme and anti-american than
it would otherwise have been
even after 20 years
the national
shame
of iran's seizure of american hostages
in 1979
and the hostage and the hardships they
endured held captive for a year and a
half
should remind us of unwise decision
decisions in the nixon era
if iran was a disaster policy area
however
the nixon administration's handling of
the arab israeli problem was a brilliant
success
in 1970 nixon and kissinger worked
closely with mrs mayer
and robin
getchakrabin to thwart a determined plo
effort to take over jordan with syria
joining in already too
a fine example of effective crisis
management
then as we've already noted
in 1973 anwar sadat in egypt attacked
israel
catching israeli forces unprepared and
also achieving what might be called
strategic surprise
by enlisting oil-rich saudi arabia to
unleash what was called the oil weapon
namely the oil embargo which hit america
and its allies hard
and threatened the western alliance
with nixon completely distracted by
watergate
it fell to henry kissinger to conduct
what came to be called shuttle diplomacy
that first ended the war with bearable
withdrawal agreements
and then country by country
brought the moderate arab countries
around
not only to let up on the oil huago but
to draw closer to the u.s
and away from the radical arab states
and movements
these basic changes for which kissinger
deserves enormous credit
were to be the foundation for all later
efforts to move toward peace between the
arab countries and israel
elusive as that peace remains
to this day
precisely to this day one might almost
say with a y plantation
overall
how should one judge the nixon
administration's foreign policies
the conclusion has to be mixed certainly
by no means the string of successes
nixon and kissinger sought to portray
in their massive memoirs
i have three main conclusions
first that while both nixon and
kissinger knew a great deal about the
world
their judgment was erratic often far too
subjective and emotional
or driven by general concepts that did
not fit with underlying reality
second while nixon could be a master
strategist and planner he lacked the
qualities
of a statesman or builder
in contrast for example to harry truman
a much less sophisticated man though
well advised by george marshall and dean
atchison he built no lasting structures
and did not enlist the congressional and
public support necessary to sustain such
structures
third and most telling of all
his on nixon's unshakable bent to
secrecy and deception
undermined his accomplishments and in
the end brought him down
not just in the political sense
watergate but in the policy sense
in short
while it was a memorable and important
period in american foreign policy
it was not
one to emulate
or in the end admire
finally if i have a minute or two more
the nixon era is a case study directly
relevant to the quest to a question we
face today
the effect of a presidential scandal on
foreign policy
the initial actions of watergate crimes
by any legal standard
were mostly burglaries to get
politically useful material for use
against democrats or critics of policy
these started in 1971 nixon's third year
in office and blossomed in 1972 and 1973
into a full-scale program
finally revealed in the spring of 1973
by the confession
of a man named james mccord
who had participated in the june 1972
burglary of democratic party national
headquarters in the watergate building
complex in washington
this triggered
senate committee hearings focused on
cover-up evidence
and then step by step
to nixon firing the first special
prosecutor archibald cox
and his attorney general elliot
richardson who refused to obey the order
to fire cox
in this so-called saturday night
massacre of october 1973
this was followed relentlessly
by the appointment of a new special
prosecutor
leon jaworski
a veteran
non-political trial lawyer and past
president of the american bar
association
the house judiciary committee committee
after receiving from a grand jury
the evidence cox and jaworski had
obtained
secrecy so total that the committee was
not even informed that the grand jury
had named nixon himself as an unindicted
co-conspirator
they went ahead the committee
to consider careful and again secret
summaries of the evidence and in july
1974
voted three articles of impeachment
rejecting two others when crossover
democratic committee members voted with
the republican minority
one of these
was the valid charge that nixon had
falsely dedicated the papers
on a large transfer of his official
papers to the government which he
claimed as a deductible gift on his
income tax
the committee concluded that since this
was not an official act it should not be
part of impeachment articles
at that climactic point
nixon was forced by a supreme court
decision
to turn over what came to be called the
smoking gun tape that showed him
ordering the cia director six days after
the burglary
to claim falsely the fbi investigations
of the of that main burglary would
interfere with cia secret operations
with the house clearly ready to propose
impeachment in the senate to vote it
nixon had no choice but to resign
end to end from mccord's confession to
the final committee votes
watergate watergate lasted 16 plunks
plus months
from every angle except possibly the
degree of media attention
it was a far bigger scandal than the
present clinton star won
in its last months nixon lost his powers
of concentration especially on the
middle east war
but he was fortunate in having kissinger
to take over
so far as far as i can tell anyway
we have seen no comparable effects in
foreign policy
but the impact of watergate
as in in that from that period
was enough to provide a strong historic
argument for dealing with the present
scandal as quickly as possible
thank you very much
thank you for being our legacy to
history
i'd like to open the florida questions
and i would ask you to please identify
yourself and keep your question brief
and to the point
arlen was an international institute for
entrepreneurship development in wilkes
university
you described nixon as
highly prone to secrecy and deception
and you also describe nixon and
kissinger as what sounds like an
imperial
presidency with the richelieu
agenda
how would you interpret
nixon today and in terms of his
his need to dominate or to
prevent information from coming out or
to cause
his policies to be
followed without any question or not to
consult others to any degree
you're inviting me to have an
analysis of his psychology in effect
and there are people who've done that i
didn't do it in the book i deliberately
stayed away from that
there are those who go back to his
boyhood in california where he was one
of the have-nots in his high school
class this kind of thing
certainly he had a
chip on his shoulder toward people that
he thought had had more advantages than
he had
and that was a factor too
um
then
i think the
the taste for secrecy
which was so basic
was already present uh i mean he
he did it i i paused to say that i think
he did an honorable and correct job in
the alger his investigation
in contrast to almost all that mccarthy
was doing in the same period
but he
and nixon developed this this bent for
secrecy
particularly in the eisenhower
administration's frequent
covert operations
the last one of which eisenhower mounted
was what became the bay of pigs under
kennedy
and nixon had supported that
he supported
that kind of action
and another thing he supported he came
to support in the eisenhower period
was the use of the threat of heavy
bombing
as a way of resolving crises
he was convinced
and i don't think the evidence really
supports this as strongly as he believed
it anyway
that in 19
see how i get this date straight in 19
when eisenhower
got the ceasefire in korea
that the decisive factor
was a threat of using nuclear weapons
conveyed i think through the indian
ambassador
nixon believed that that kind of
dramatic threat
was a very decisive way of acting
and did it himself
vainly in 1969 briefly in an ultimatum
he gave the north vietnamese
those all those
elements of his
character and i've used examples from
foreign policy
were deeply rooted and
they continued to be i suppose i haven't
followed them
in in areas of domestic policy or
but you can you can see it
uh his constant
feeling for
the next political maneuver he could
make
one of the most revealing sources in the
work i did was
the diaries of h.r haldeman
nixon's chief of staff
and
the these reveal the degree to which
nixon would lock himself up or not lock
himself but but isolate himself in the
executive office building
and write out all kinds of ideas of
people he could talk to influence
manipulate
and then give the list to haldeman to
pursue
that was
that was his his nature and his practice
in the political arena and it to the
maximum degree he could
in the foreign policy one
yes
uh richard valcourt international
journal of intelligence um i was struck
by your inclusion of leonard brezhnev as
one of the outstanding leaders of that
period it's become fashionable to have a
void between nikita khrushchev and the
kyle gorbachev so could you elaborate a
little bit on your assessment of
brushnap for that long period that he
ruled russia
no i wouldn't be able to mount a
full-scale
appraisal of his entire tenure which
varied enormously i think he was just an
apparatchik or someone judged for a very
long period
but i think one can see him emerging in
the nixon period
as a man who thought independently or at
least to a degree independently that's
relative word of course in the soviet
decision-making structure
but he seemed to be truly in charge
on many occasions
which was not the case at the beginning
and i think had not been the case in
earlier periods
you can see that
things that seem to be authentically
brezhnev
included for example and this was a
rather dramatic episode
in 1973 in the second summit
the summit held here return engagement
brezhnev
summoned nixon in the middle of the
night out at san clemente
to urge him in the strongest terms
to get the arab-israel situation
resolved so that there wouldn't be a war
i think that was brezhnev
thinking he could use the situation at a
particular moment his tie with nixon
which by then had become quite close
to get the u.s to intervene
and
nip the 1973 war preparation is already
visible in the bud
now i may be wrong we don't have the
soviet papers that really show who was
powerful and who was not
but my reading is that nixon
not nixon brezhnev of course i mean
uh was increasingly powerful in the
soviet structure throughout this period
i think you've got jim billington come
coming a little
later in the month and maybe i'd better
say ask him
my old friend
oh yes i'm sorry mr bundy
chester berger
would you care to say anything about
the
abdominal theory as a factor in
development of policy in southeast asia
and subsequently
what you think the last period is shown
about it
right well that's right on point of
course and i have a have a couple of
pages
devoted to that precise question
uh in the book
of course the domino theory was not
invoked it really dated back to
the kennedy period
into 1964 65
uh
in its in it that was its simplified
version i think that the phrase was ice
with eisenhower's
uh
but the way it was finally and it's more
sophisticated form it was that the
uh
overall communist threat in southeast
asia
china on the one hand in north vietname
vietnam on the other even though they
were not regarded
as a team or that north china was in
charge
that they would put pressure on what
were in fact very certainly very
vulnerable and unstable non-communist
nations
and that if
the vietnam war turned out in the favor
of the communist side this would be
enormously
increased
certainly
it had a certain plausibility to it
i never liked it i never never liked the
phrasing certainly i never you don't
think i ever used the word domino theory
in my years in office
but
the
feeling in southeast asia at the time
was indeed palpable
and my personal index of it was quite
largely
the then i thought very attractive and
certainly interesting character lee kuan
yew in singapore
who was neutral
and remained neutral but who gave me a
tremendous lecture and i'll never forget
it
that we had to stand or the wind would
blow from the east was the phrase he
used
that was the feeling of the nations in
the area
and that was a great part of the
evidence that led us to attach very
significant weight to this factor
now
jumping ahead
i have described in the book how when
after
congress had
ended u.s participation
and in a succession of situations the
communists again went on the offensive
and of course captured saigon and took
over the whole country in 1975
that was
many people took that to me
and
and then the
critical bit after that
is that this the dominoes didn't fall
that the southeast asian nations did not
turn communist or give any particular
sign of doing so in 1975.
so many people have drawn the
conclusion that the domino theory in its
simplified or sophisticated forms
was just simply not valid
i've expressed my view that at
particular times in 6465 was one of them
it did seem to me to have considerable
weight
and i believe
and i tried this at a conference of
historians about three years ago and i
was surprised to find that they listened
carefully
that
the
steps that we took our presence in
indochina
they are carrying on with the war
did
help to improve confidence
in the intervening years
so that what had been particularly weak
and vulnerable nations in southeast asia
were by 1975 considerably stronger
now that doesn't say for a minute
that
the war was worth its costs of all sorts
but that there was this one aspect of
gain
now
to get to that point you have to analyze
the crucial change that took place in
southeast asia in 6566
which was the
dramatic
ouster of sicarno and his replacement by
a man who then appeared to be quote a
good guy
suharto
and
that changeover which we had no reason
to expect did not expect and responded
to by a policy of total silence
was an enormous change in the whole
makeup of southeast asia and if you let
me run on for a moment longer
i vividly recall
speaking across the street at the
council in spring of 1966
on the situation as it then appeared
and having george cannon in the front
row
and george
held up his hand and i naturally called
on him
he said don't you think
that now with the changed situation in
indonesia
the factors that led to the american
intervention are now so much weakened
that we could afford to turn to a much
less participatory and involved policy
i'm afraid i made sputtering noises
about china still being a threat
i think george was emphatically right
it was what general gavin was saying at
the time from the military standpoint
hunker down and protect what you've got
on the coast but don't try to
really win the war militarily
it was also what another man whom i have
enormous admiration senator aiken said
declare victory and go home
and it was what mike mansfield an old
friend and of course a very great
senator
an expert on asia was saying
i have come to believe and i don't know
why i got started on this but since you
asked
i have come to believe that that was a
time when we might have pulled out
with
considerable improvement in the
situation in southeast asia
with an infinite reduction in the cost
to the united states
and not attempted after that to win
the war militarily just had it as a
holding operation as general gavin urged
to me that's the biggest what-if
in the whole analysis of possible
alternatives during the war
i didn't intend to talk about it but now
that you mentioned it i'm glad you did
the last question over here please
douglas aides from the polish american
enterprise fund
um you made a brief allusion to massive
aid to russia as i think you indicated
it was a missed opportunity in the past
how would you view that today
i don't have an expert view i'm
strictly
newspaper reader as far as the situation
in russia is concerned
i think it so much depends
this is an obvious point it so much
depends on who you're working with
i mean if you had a government in place
in russia
that could effectively carry out any
semblance of policy in the economic
front
then you might have something to work
with
i don't see that and therefore i don't
think it is a realistic option at the
present time
uh whether it might have a potential but
nixon i've forgotten exactly when nixon
did make that proposal it was in an
article in time magazine with a
considerable splash
and it was as everything he wrote was it
was very well constructed and argued
uh
and i just don't remember exactly what
the situation then was but certainly it
was more hopeful than it could ever be
if you tried that that
move today
ignorant answer to a good question
i thank you for being with us and taking
us back into history
mr bundy's book is available for sale
and he will be very happy to autograph
it for you thank you for being with us
thank you very much
[Applause]
it was better than all right it was
wonderful
[Music]
william bundy was the editor of foreign
affairs magazine for more than 10 years
his book a tangled web is published by
hill and wang at 19 union square west
new york new york one zero zero zero
three
[Music]